you can't spit on the sidewalk
if you live with somebody for seven
years of the opposite sex you are
considered married it's the common-law
married Act I just made that up in
Virginia it's illegal to have more than
five women in a house because it's
considered a brothel
[Music]
no oral sex
so if you grew up in Virginia you
probably went Jamestown which was really
weird and apparently is sinking right
now
robert e lee day was the same day as
Martin Luther King Day I'm gonna
pronounce how you would say it and how
we say it
so there's Buchanan what you say as
Buckhannon there is but that's uh what
you say is but it's sad
Staunton which you call Bank Blane
Avista which is Buena Vista Norfolk is
pronounced more [ __ ] we got a Wayne
Newton award for breakout artist in
Roanoke
because Wayne Newton apparently lived in
Roanoke for maybe like a hot second Dave
Ruel is from my home town of Alexandria
Virginia their claim to fame across the
street for my house there was this
barbecue place and that's where high
school jared leto
used to work the Virginia flag is pretty
intense
it's a woman warrior stepping on this
this other dude what is the story on
that really basically a woman standing
on top of a dead tyrant death to tyrants
when I was five or six I had a pet cow
named Blackie to chase my brother up a
tree and was later killed by wild dogs
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]